let me say uh welcome to everybody for
this
second hall light hall session on stoic
practices in epictetuses
and caridian um this is a new platform
for online learning some of you have
been here before i think some of you are
probably
new to this as well and lighthall was
founded in part because there's this
view i think right
rightly considered that
there's a lot of online classes a lot of
things that people can participate in
but there's really no substitute
for
live interaction for doing the kind of
things that happen in a class session
where
you know things could go wrong as they
did at the very start or unpredictable
events can happen or people can you know
ask really good questions that lead us
into interesting digressions or stuff
like that so lighthall is devoted to
that and i'm going to be putting more
classes on lighthall
the classes are also recorded and wind
up in my youtube
channel as well as on lightholm
so i
created a class session
i think it was about a maybe a month ago
or a couple weeks ago
and i decided to focus on epictetuses
and coridian which is a classic stoic
text
and thought that i might um
focus on what we call practices
and so what we're doing here is we're
zeroing in on stoic philosophy zeroing
even more in an epictetus even more on
his short text the end caridian or
handbook and then looking at some
specific passages
so that we can isolate out some
practices that will be
very helpful for people and it was so um
popular
that i thought well let's let's do
another session along those same lines
because there's
many many stoic practices in epictetus
and we could probably keep on doing
these for for months to come
so um i picked five practices the first
time that i thought were really helpful
i've picked another five practices that
i think
all of you could probably
use one of them is actually a favorite
of my wife andy who is
currently
on this class
the the one about the the dinner party
which we'll get to in a bit
and i'm i should point out that i'm
using the old father translation out of
convenience not because it's the
best translation there is no best
translation of epictetus or really of
most philosophical texts and i'm using
my my lobe edition and that's why i'm
using the old father it's got the greek
and the english on facing pages and so
it's convenient for me
and that's what's in the handout that i
i gave you the um
english on one side old father
translation the
greek on the other side for those who'd
like to check it against the the actual
text itself so
what we're going to do
is i've got five practices lined up for
you
and we're going to look at the relevant
passage from the endcaridian that i have
in that handout for you and then we're
going to discuss some of the basic
concepts or ideas involved in that
practice i will point out some ways in
which i've seen beginners sometimes go
wrong in trying to understand or apply
these practices
and then we'll also look at some other
passages in epictetus that give us
additional examples or some
amplification on these ideas and we'll
look at some contemporary examples i've
got something lined up for each of you
and then we'll do q a so we're going to
pause for q a
at um five different points in this
this little class session that we're
having and then at the end whatever time
we have left over
we'll um
we'll use that for general q a so any
anything that you know is not
specifically about those
practices you might want to hold off on
until the very end
and i do want to say something very
quickly that i did say in the first
session but i just want to you know
reiterate it for anybody who wasn't
there about philosophical
practices
so these get called a lot of different
things if you've ever read pirado you
know who popularized the phrase
philosophy as a way of life although
he's he's certainly not the first person
to work with that concept he calls them
spiritual exercises uh michelle cole
likes the word technologies of the self
these all mean the same thing
essentially philosophical practices are
things that you're getting from a
philosophical tradition
and they have to do with you know uh the
really big you know picture sort of
things what is human nature where do we
fit in in the world how can we make
ourselves less screwed up uh than we
currently are which is actually a big
question and their ways of um
trying to answer those questions by
saying you should try this or you should
do this experiment with this they're not
saying they'll work every single time
they're not like pushing a button they
do require some some you know thinking
and application they're not they're not
cookie cutter stuff they're not life
hacks
each of these practices is something
that as you do practice you get better
and better at and you understand it more
fully the more that you apply it and
reflect on it and because stoicism is
like a vast interconnected system
of philosophy not life hacks again as i
was saying
as you get good at one practice you're
going to find that will typically inform
other practices it'll these things
connect up together in ways that
sometimes you don't see
right at the start but
you can see more and more as as time
goes on
they all have
a couple different dimensions or
components that are connected together
cognitive right what we're thinking what
we know or at least think we know what
we what we deliberately tell ourselves
mentally
affective that means feeling wise
desires drives all those sorts of things
choice an incredibly important thing for
the stoics and then finally action what
do we actually do and i i suppose you
could also say that there's a fifth
important component to this as well
namely
that
what we um
experience right so the affective is
kind of part of that you know our
feelings
but we could also say that we have
experiences when we try applying these
you know maybe
um they don't go quite as well and then
we can you know tie in these other
things did i think things through right
did i make the right choices did i screw
up in my action so all of those are
important aspects um let's jump into the
first one
so this comes
uh from end caribbean chapter 20.
but but it's running throughout the end
caribbean and stoic practice in general
epictetus tells us here's the the
relevant passage
make it your first endeavor not to be
carried away by the external impression
for if once you gain time and delay
you will more easily become master of
yourself now
what's going on there this is where we
need to talk about some basic concepts
and some
terms so the term there
impression what is an impression this is
a technical term in the stoic vocabulary
and actually not just the stoics but all
the ancient virtue ethicists
use this this term
fantasia which can be translated as
impression it can also be translated
very often as appearance
it also means imagination fontasia is is
the faculty of imagination and also the
imaginations that we have so it's it's
covering a lot of ground and it's not
just images it could you could have a
smell that is
an appearance right
and then you
judge something based on that
a lot of the things that are in your
mind already are also appearances
because reason and we'll talk about the
implications for this reason epictetus
tells us is a system a sustema connected
matrix of appearances
so we're running into these things all
the time and you could call them
impressions if you like because that
gets across the idea that they're like
pushing themselves
upon us which really fits this
particular passage well
we're living in a world where we're
bombarded by information some of it just
you know the way things work you know
you open your car door or you get on the
bus and suddenly you know there's
there's stairs or the seat in front of
you that's an impression right
probably a true one um i take a sip from
my coffee
i now have an impression of coffee taste
along with half and half that i mixed in
with it we could go on and on and on
and a lot of the impressions that we run
into
they're very quickly connected with
judgments or opinions doksai in
in
the greek that epictetus uses and so
learning how to deal with these in
productive ways what the stoics call in
accordance with nature or rightly or
virtuously
this is incredibly important because
if we don't do that
we
wind up making all sorts of you could
call them automatic reasoning processes
or automatic
feelings arising or
you know there's other ways of thinking
about this if we're not
taking a pause every once in a while and
saying is
what i think is in front of me is this
really what's going on
we can become very reactive and when we
do that we generally become a prey to
our own
rather
poorly organized ways of of associating
things and you know we become subject to
an entire world that's out there
you know ready to scoop us up and bring
us into things so
epictetus actually tells us we need to
take a pause we need to
impose a little time and delay as he
says this doesn't mean that we need to
like sit there and become completely
naval gazing for hours upon hours or
anything like that
but in our ordinary life we do want to
take a pause occasionally when something
is in front of us
and see what's really there you know and
and quite often i think all of us have
had this experience of taking a pause
and not reacting immediately not
engaging the thoughts or actions or
choices that we would normally do
and then seeing that things are not as
they originally appeared
now
beginners will sometimes
mess up in two different ways with this
one of them is taking too long of a
pause this is not saying that you should
like
you know for every single thing in in
your life um stop and consider it
because you would you know the day would
quickly escape you um you don't want to
get caught in
loops of like dithering and endless
reflection you still do have to act and
make decisions and
do things in the world um the other
thing that often happens with beginners
is um trying to do too much
um you know and this is actually i
should point out this is a problem for
beginners with every one of these
practices you typically have to do this
in one area of your life and then try to
shift to another area of your life where
you can like start adding that in sort
of like if you if you start going to the
gym
to get back in shape you don't do every
single exercise right
you pick something get good at that then
start adding other things in so that
that's something you can do epictetus
has a couple cool uh passages where he's
talking about
this chapter 6 he reminds us
what then is your own the use of
external impressions therefore when
you're in harmony with nature in the use
of external impressions then be happy be
elated for it will be some good of your
own at which you will be elated
in chapter one he actually suggests that
when we run into harsh troubling is
another way of translating it external
impressions he says make it there for
your study to say to every harsh
external impression you
are an external impression and not at
all what you appear to be
after that examine it and test it by
those rules you have the first and most
important of which is this whether the
impression has to do with the things
under our control over the things not
under our control
and if it has no some if it has to do
with one of the things that's not under
our control have ready at hand the
answer it's nothing to me so he's
suggesting that whenever we run into
something that would bother us that
would get us angry that would get us
fearful would get us upset
we stop and
say okay are things really the way that
i think that they are let's let's think
about this we can also do this with
pleasant things things that we enjoy in
chapter 34.
he suggests and there's an entire longer
practice associated with this but this
is just the part we want when you get an
external impression of some pleasure
guard yourself as with impressions in
general against being carried away by it
nay let the matter wait on your leisure
and give yourself a little delay so we
see again
this counseling take pause don't jump in
right away um you know an example of
this could be
you go to
a place and it's a restaurant and you
know you see somebody else and they've
got a dish that looks really good and
smells good you're like oh that's that's
what i want i'm having that
well
you know you don't know whether it
really is as good as you think and so
you shouldn't jump right into to those
matters now you know what are some
contemporary examples that we can think
of um well here's one
why do we get into so many
conflicts and arguments with other
people
when we're communicating with them
well because they say something
and then we think that we're a mind
reader and we can figure out what their
motive or their subtext is
that's an
impression what they're saying is an
impression
and then you know we also are like
bringing a new
fantasia new impression to the the scene
um and then we wind up with this
judgment oh they're denigrating me oh
they're they're not you know willing to
hear what i have to say oh they said
something i don't like and that's
because they're a bad person those are
all snap judgments that we make because
we didn't pause to
examine our impressions or appearances
so let's take a little pause for q a at
this point what about this
is
unclear
doesn't make sense
those are the best places to start
things that
you're like well i'm not quite sure what
i do with this
uh or you know do you think it's it's
pretty straightforward just something
that we don't do often enough i know
that this is something i struggle with
even today after you know practicing
stoicism for a long time you have to
keep doing these sorts of practices so
what questions do people have
i mean actually um i'll take something
while people are writing uh so at the
beginning of the session um things got
wonky as far as the chat and as far as
the uh
uh the interface you know
now i could have had the impression
oh my gosh this this uh this is just a
catastrophe i can't do this right
that could be an impression but you know
you just take a pause and say
uh you know there's probably something i
can figure out with this i need to just
be kind of careful with it all right so
dirk has a question how to avoid being
carried away by the moment
yeah so uh you won't be able to in every
case right and this goes back to that
beginner
advice or beginner problems but
you can remind yourself you might
actually do this if you decide to make
this a practice you might get up in the
morning
and remind yourself hey i'm going to run
into a lot of
impressions today and
i'm probably going to need to like take
a pause and examine at least some of
them and that's how you do it you you
actually deliberately tell yourself whoa
whoa hang on a second buddy you know
great example of this is when you get
angry one of the
bits of advice that sounds really
trivial and simple and even kind of
stupid is to count to ten
turns out that's awfully helpful you
know
uh you you doesn't necessarily take away
the feeling of anger but it does afford
that pause which is important so you
might you know have to impose it on
yourself and it will feel artificial at
first when you do it
a says as someone who has a lot of
difficulty making decisions how should
we make a final judgment decision after
examining an impression are there any
tips for this well epictetus gave you
one right there
is this thing falling within the scope
of what's in your control or what's not
in your control right there's there's a
rule there's a whole bunch
of rules throughout epictetus and
caridian and his larger discourses and
the rest of um
you could say stoic literature that we
possess because we still do have an
awful lot even though we've lost even
more than we we possess
and there's lots and lots of of
rules that you could adapt from that
that would be be quite helpful
um
vincent i'm new to all this is the pause
similar to what i've read of as prosoke
becoming a more aware observers thoughts
as they occur
so
similar no um connected to yes
prosocce
means attentiveness sometimes it gets
translated as mindfulness
and it doesn't just mean attentiveness
to the thoughts that you're having it
means also attentiveness to your
environment paying attention to what's
out there paying attention to how other
people are reacting and perhaps even you
know um
vulnerabilities that that they have that
we need to be careful about you know
so um
you know prosoke is gonna help and you
can have pros okay or attentiveness of
the fact that you actually do need to
take pauses right but this is a
different uh practice and by the way i
brought up pierre ado a little bit
earlier he actually considers
attentiveness or prosoke or whatever you
want to call it as like its own separate
class of practice
in his
philosophy as a way of life so that
could be quite interesting
um
dustin says i've been experimenting with
marking in my habit journal amp the
times i kept my sword sheets so i'm i'm
expecting this has to do with conflict
and not retaliating
this is a pause in saying or taking a
reactive reaction yeah so that's
journaling writing down things is
another
kind of practice that can reinforce this
and you can use that with any of these
practices that were
we're looking at
um
jay has uh says i have a mantra i've
developed over the years stop breathe
think act is this sort of what you're
talking about yeah it's very similar
except in this case it's not just about
stop breathe think act it's
look at the impressions that are in
front of you and you know examine them
i'll take one last
question and then we'll move on to the
next one from nancy i find i do
sometimes jump to a negative impression
based on previous experience with the
person i now try to take a pause and
consider my response which could include
physically excusing myself from the
situation so two really good points
there
one to talk about like physically
removing yourself from the situation
there isn't just one way to take a pause
right and
removing yourself from a situation that
you know that you're otherwise going to
like get riled up in
is a prudent move on the part of the the
person who's trying to take a pause
right
there might be other ways to take a
pause maybe we need to look away from
our screen if we're doing something
that's um internet-based right or mobile
technology based um there's there's
there may be things where we need to
isolate ourselves out in order to
actually take a pause and then jumping
to a negative impression based on
previous experiences with a person
totally
natural
but also something that we want to try
to
bring into question right
i mean it could be that the person
epictetus doesn't say that you know a
harsh impression isn't harsh
right maybe the person you're dealing
with really is a sadistic
uh you know
exploitative jerk
um and you were right about them the
first time but
maybe that's not the case right and so
this this helps us very much in our
interpersonal life to respond to people
not just based on
the past that we think we know but on
what's actually in front of us so that
those are some very good points
let's talk about the um second practice
now
responding to impediments i call this
and
epictetus says in chapter 9
disease is an impediment to the body but
not to the moral purpose unless that
consents
lameness is an impediment to the leg but
not to the moral purpose
and say this to yourself at each thing
that befalls you for you will find the
thing to be an impediment to something
else
but not to yourself
now the word impediment there
um
in greek it's empodion you can think of
it as a you know something that that
humbles you that that impedes you that
hinders you that
ties your your legs together hobbles you
that's the word i was looking for rather
than humble
and epictetus is not denying that things
can be in fact impediments but
there's something
that
is not impeded by all these other things
that we consider to be impediments here
it's translated as moral purpose
the greek word for it is pro-racist we
sometimes translate that as faculty of
choice or will
or other things as as well and this
epictetus says this is the core of who
you are
the the field of what's in your control
is where your pro-irasis
extends to right
so
you know can you
make yourself think about something yeah
well that falls within the scope of your
pro-erasis
now there could be impediments you know
you you can't just turn yourself into
some sort of brainiac
no matter what kind of monomic devices
you use you know there's things you're
going to forget there's thoughts that
you're going to have that arise unbidden
as we say right or feelings
but
for the most part you are epictetus says
in charge of your own mind
and what you think and what you feel and
whether you
choose to
have good reasoning processes or not one
thing you're definitely not in charge of
is um
somebody else's mind right you can try
to influence them but there that that
that's a whole other world
that they have control over and you
don't so there is this thing within us
which is the core of who we are that
can't be impeded by anything or any
anyone else unless as he says it it
chooses or consents
um the greek word there is thele and and
that means to to wish to decide
so there are a lot of other things
though in the world that can be impeded
he talks about her body right so
somebody can put a
shackle on your leg somebody can as
unfortunately happen to epictetus damage
your leg and you can become lame
i'm missing two ligaments in my my left
knee
they've been gone for about 10 years now
so i can't run or i can but it's awfully
painful
and that's an impediment for my body but
that's not an impediment for my
pro erasers or faculty of choice
there's a lot of things in our life that
that can be wealth
position um whether the the internet
works or not like i'm going to talk
about in just a little bit um all of
those are things that can be
impeded and rightly so because that's
the way the world works you know um if
you
well you know take this this coffee here
right there's certain physical laws that
apply to it if i try drinking too much
of it you know and suddenly coffee comes
comes out of my nose or i start choking
or something that's an impediment it
would be an impediment also to me
talking to you here
but that's just the way things are right
um
the universe is arranged in in
complex ways that
typically work the same way so is the
social world
and
we need to be able to distinguish
between where we are impeded and where
we aren't you know to use the leg
example so epictetus was lame and he
there's nothing he could do about that
i'm also kind of lame
i have done what i can do about it which
is to basically as my doctor said max
out building the muscles that will help
to stabilize the knee
and that's it you know so that's that's
an impediment but
what i do with that whether i feel bad
whether i feel okay
whether i continue to take walks or
whether i say oh if i can't if i can't
you know walk perfectly i'm not going to
take walks
totally up to me right i am not hindered
in that respect
so epictetus um tells us um this is in
chapter one of the end caribbean the
things under our control
are by nature free unhindered there's
that word again and unimpeded
the things not under our control he says
are subject to hindrance and not our own
so if you
think that things that are naturally you
know impedable
uh are free and what's not your own to
be your own you are going to be hampered
you're going to be held back
well if you think only what is your own
to be your own and what is not your own
to be as it really is not your own
no one will be able to hinder you
so again we we sort of restrict
ourselves to the things that we we
actually know we can
do something about
he's got another thing that he says in
chapter 48
one of the signs of a person who's
making progress is
when they do find themselves hampered or
prevented
they blame themselves they
rightly assign the responsibility to
themselves so they don't say oh it's
because the government oh it's because
you know my neighbor oh you know that
this stupid coffee if it was just better
coffee or you know they don't make
excuses like that if they find
themselves having allowed themselves to
get emotionally invested in things that
are outside of their control as we do
all the time um you know we're not
perfect sages and then you know things
hamper them things don't turn out the
way that they want they find themselves
impeded they can't do what they want or
get what they want they say oh i screwed
up i'm the one who actually
messed these these things up
some contemporary examples you know we
live in a world that is so incredibly
interdependent uh in our contemporary
life not just upon you know
complex causal interactions but also on
other people and the decisions that they
make
vast systems that we only see little
bits of you know think about all the
people who are you know complaining
about gas prices right now
is it you know is it the biden
administration is it the oil companies
is it the supply chains well it's it's
all sorts of things right
um and
if you you know if you're going to allow
that to become something that gets you
worked up you know the cost of a
particular commodity
you're laying yourself in for a lot of
aggravation and that's that's a way of
being hindered
our entire internet interface is a great
example of how we can so easily
be hindered it's dependent on what
companies decide to do random glitches
or interferences all the hardware that's
involved a very important youtube
channel
brian van norden's channel on chinese
philosophy was taken down by a youtube
bot and then he was locked out of his
channel and only fortunately through the
intervention of other people because he
made a public stink about it was that
channel reinstated
and it was able to be reinstated because
youtube didn't delete anything they just
took it out of commission
these things these impediments can arise
so easily in anything involving the the
internet
let's turn now to some some questions
um and i do want to hit on this one from
andre from the previous one does
epictetus give any advice around dealing
with other people's non-objective
impressions um i mean he wouldn't say
non-objective he'd say incorrect right
um i'm currently trying to help a friend
with drug abuse with episodes of
psychosis
epictetus would say um you can do your
part but you're not going to change
their mind it you know it's very similar
to like therapy right people don't
they don't get much out of therapy until
they decide that i want to
do something with this right
and um you know epictetus says no person
is is a master over another's pro-irasis
unless they choose to like give that
person
mastery and your friend is probably not
going to do that right so
um
it's a long hard road in dealing with
with
abuse and addiction
mental illness is also quite difficult
if they really have psychosis that is
some difficult stuff
so you know
keep your expectations low and realize
that they are
an independent entity of you you can do
whatever you can to help your friend but
that's it there's no there's no
guarantee that it's going to
andrew says what about automatic
thoughts and ruminating so two different
things right two very very different
things
act says there's no control over these
thoughts and one should just ignore the
thoughts and get on with life so
um
that's a one one-size-fits-all
response that so that you should be
suspicious of that right off the bat
um automatic thoughts
how are they automatic right this is
something you want to think about do
they are they always going to arise
by themselves or are they only arising
in certain situations where you can
figure out what the triggers are
or
um
as you you know develop yourself do you
find some of them going away if so then
we're dealing with kind of different
animals here right
um
and ruminating now so you can have all
sorts of thoughts that arise as we say
automatically and when you have that
happening you can actually analyze them
that's that's part of what stoics do
they say what are our thought processes
how are we getting to this appearance at
this point what's what's behind that
um ruminating is something that you have
more of a choice about right because
ruminating is a it's not just a thought
pops in your head you're like sitting
there and you're dwelling on it and
you're not thinking about other things
that you could choose to think about
that would result in you not ruminating
or not ruminating as much and and you
keep doing it and it's you know it's
it's understandable why people do
ruminate because the thoughts that they
have that they're dwelling over right
that they're chewing on literally that's
what ruminating is
um are
ones that kind of draw the person into
them there's a kind of attraction to
them they they present themselves as you
know the way things are so when you get
depressed
uh and ruminate when you get anxious and
ruminate those those are the sorts of
things that are happening
and epictetus isn't claiming and no
stoic claims that you can just like snap
your fingers and think anything that you
like and be you know totally happy in
your life you you have a lot of work
that you have to do
but what you decide to do with automatic
thoughts and what you decide to do when
you find yourself ruminating
that is up to you
so you can't like just turn them off
automatically
and you don't necessarily just have to
ignore them i mean you can analyze them
you can rebut them you know like if
you're doing negative self-talk you can
do positive self-talk that's what cbt
tells you to do right so um
just because a ct says one therapeutic
modality says do things doesn't mean
other therapeutic modalities might not
tell us other things so so these you
know these can be quite helpful and
those are some good questions because
all of us have you know when we see
epictetus in encouraging one saying our
you know our thoughts our
desires and aversions these are totally
up to us there's a tendency for people
to think that oh that means that like
we don't have um thoughts that arise by
themselves or feelings that we get hit
with some some days you wake up in the
morning
and uh you're already in a mood right so
all right let's take a look at the third
one and this is this is a good segue
into it
redirecting desire and aversion
so epictetus tells us something in
chapter two
withdraw therefore your aversion from
all the matters that are not under our
control and transfer it to what is
unnatural among those which are under
our control but for the time being
remove utterly your desire for if you
desire some one of the things that are
not under our control you're bound to be
unfortunate and at the same time not one
of the things that are under our control
which it would be excellent for you to
desire is within your grasp
but employ only choice and refusal and
these two but lightly and with
reservations and without straining
so this is a very interesting passage
and i'll tell you that this is one that
i've had um
clients
you know who are getting into stoicism
and they're like i think this is going
to help me out but
what the hell does this mean and how the
hell do i do it right people who've been
doing other um
philosophical or spiritual practices
they encounter this and they're like
how do you how do you do this how do you
withdraw
aversion and transfer it and then how do
you utterly remove your desire and the
answer is
you know you you can't do it all at once
um and so let's talk about some of the
key ideas here so
he does say that
um desire and aversion right uh orexis
uh
you know is desire choice is jorme or
impulse
that these things and their opposites
desire and aversion choice and refusal
choosing against
are under our control
now does that mean going back to like
you know the question about automatic
thoughts
um
does that mean that like our desires are
so simple we can just like you know
almost like pull them out of a
socket and then plug them back into
something else no no it doesn't work
like that it's it's not quite so simple
and people may have really really deep
rooted
reasons for why they desire or are
averse to the things
that they have like you know if they
have a phobia for example or if they've
undergone some trauma or they or you
know to go back to another uh
earlier question addiction right when
you develop an addiction an addiction is
really a set of desires
that are very very strong and are going
in a constant direction
so
um it's not it's not as easy as just
like saying okay i i'm no longer
desiring oh for example i used to be a
smoker you know smoked cigarettes loved
smoking cigarettes there were so many
things about it um that were not good
like you know the lung damage and your
clothes stinking but boy did you know
tobacco tastes good with coffee
and with beer and you know even just by
itself
you have all these little rituals that
you develop it's it's a form of
social bonding when you hang out with
the other smokers um
so there's a lot there right all these
desires that get get built into it as
well as an aversion to not not having
tobacco you know because it feels bad um
you can quit smoking
it's not easy
i've quit many times
the last time was for good um
although i have a cigar occasionally
like on my birthday um but you know
the other times didn't take
why not well because you still keep
desiring things and you give in to those
desires eventually
so how can we do this then
there isn't one like set of rules or
procedures for withdrawing or
transferring our desire and aversion it
can be very helpful to make use of the
cognitive devices that the stoics give
us where they say think about this you
know if you
can remind yourself uh let you know
further the smoking just how bad the
smoking is for you then that might help
you slowly slowly withdraw your desire
from uh the tobacco right or other
things as well
we could also use this you know you know
how good it feels to say a cutting word
to somebody to retaliate against them
being a jerk
that's probably something that we need
to pare back on but if you know that
that kind of desire that's something
that you would want to pair back and you
could remind yourself that you're not
doing any good in the situation by
retaliating against them right you're
not gonna change their mind
so epictetus says that we need to shift
desire and aversion to the things that
are inside of our control now what does
that mean so
does this mean that we can't desire
anything
i can desire to be a good person that's
under my control right ultimately
whether i develop the virtues or not
whether i behave rationally
like a good
person in society
those are up to me so if i shift my
desire away from like wanting to be
you know um
esteemed by everybody and
have tons and tons of money you know or
um be attractive or pick pick any of
these other things that we don't really
have that much control over
um
the more that you focus your desires
inwardly on what kind of person you want
to be whether you want to be able to do
these other practices like taking a
pause or
um you know responding to impediments or
the others that we're going to talk
about
that's something that you can do he also
talks about
um uh transferring your
aversion that's that's the opposite of
desire aversion is you want something
not to be there
transferring it to the things that are
unnatural
under among those under our control so
what would that mean
the things about you that are
bad that are screwed up that are
um not helping you that are getting in
your way right those are the things that
you really should be averse to
so if i discover
within myself well i'll use my own
example you know when you get angry with
people as i've done many times in my
life you generally act like kind of a
jerk and you know put relationships at
risk and other things as well
that's something that's not good
and you know for me as somebody who has
to deal with anger since my my childhood
i can transfer my aversion to that and
say
i don't want to be that kind of person
you know that i don't want that to be
part of me
now that's not going to automatically
change that but making yourself averse
to the things about yourself that
actually you you can work on is is a
good thing from a stoic perspective
what about this using choice and refusal
lightly and with reservations and
without straining so choice and desire
are not the same thing choice is where
you know desire turns into action
um likewise uh refusal is where aversion
turns into action
so using these lightly you know just
being kind of
restrained
with reservations now the greek for that
the word for reservation
is closely connected to the word that we
talked about just earlier pro-erasis
it's um hoop x-iresis right so it's the
same thing hoop x you know again with
sort of like holding yourself back in
how you're
choosing something
and without straining without making it
unnatural for yourself
beginners get mixed up about this sort
of thing um in two main ways one is
trying to do this all at once you cannot
do this all at once it's just not
possible
and when people try to do that they they
often get discouraged but the other
is not realizing
that this is a matter both of
deliberate choosing
habituation
and reworking your reasoning processes
right so
it's not so simple as just like
turning a hose to go one way instead of
another
we have to use
a lot of cognitive work to do this and
it may actually be something that you do
in therapy with somebody else helping
you or in counseling or something like
that now epictetus has a couple
interesting things to say about this i
just want to bring up two
passages he talks about this in chapter
48 and he says that a sign of a person
who's making progress is they go around
like an invalid being careful not to
disturb before it's grown firm any part
that is getting well
they've put away from themselves
their desires and transferred their
aversions to those things only of what
is under our control that are contrary
to nature contrary to our fully
developed human nature
he exercises no pronounced choice in
regard to anything if he gives the
appearance of being foolish or ignorant
he he doesn't care he keeps guard
against himself as though he were his
own enemy lying in weight now
we are often times our own enemy
lying in weight because we've got all
these screwed up dynamics and
you know habits and associations that we
don't you know often realize until we
start making them actual and then we
make ourselves unhappy
he also says in chapter 31 that you know
if we withdraw our idea of the good and
evil from things that are not under our
control and we put it deliberately
under those that are under our control
um we're going to be much better off if
you think any of those
things that are outside of our control
to be good or evil when you fail to get
what you want and fall into what you
don't want it is inevitable that you
will blame and hate those who are
responsible for these results and he
says it's it's the nature of every
living creature
to flee from and turn aside from the
things that appear harmful and all that
produces them and to pursue
and admire the things that are helpful
and what produces them so
we have to be careful as he says to
exercise desire and aversion as we
should right
now some you know contemporary examples
of this
think about scheduling
we schedule all these things to happen
at different times
we're desiring that things turn out a
certain way right we're also averse to
uh certain things we don't like things
being put off unless of course we
haven't done our work and then we're
like hey let's let's put this off for a
week right
we can schedule things as much as we
want that's that's in our control right
we can create google calendars like i
use
whether or not things turn out that way
totally not under our control right we
can
set up the best possible event and
schedule
and everything can go haywire and that's
just the kind of the nature of things so
if we keep our desire and aversion
focused on the sphere of what we
actually do control we're going to be
better off so andrew has a good question
here say you desire money you're also
averse to not having money
it's unfortunate to fall into fail and
desire but misfortune to fail fall into
what you don't want how to separate the
two you don't have to separate the two i
mean you could look at them as being two
sides of the same coin or you could say
that um you're desiring wealth and
you're averse to poverty which is not
just not having wealth but it's all the
other things epictetus talks about this
in an actual chapter on on fearing
poverty um it's it's all the other
things that go along with it and um
you don't necessarily have to separate
desire and aversion if you think that
they're closely linked to each other
there are plenty of things that we do
desire and we're not averse to the
absence of
you know there are plenty of things that
we're averse to and we're not desiring
the opposite of
um so this doesn't hold for for
everything but
you know um
that's that that that's a a good idea
and what we have to do with all of them
is over and over again we have to we
have to choose
to
either like
redirect our desires or to to think
about things in such a way that will
help us
not necessarily
totally cut off desire but at least
desire less um you know again we'll use
the smoking for an example right
so
again like i said
when i was smoking i loved smoking
you know i mean that's part of why it
gets addictive right that's why it's a
whole industry
i could remind myself
as i'm desiring the cigarette i could
like bring up you know things and say
well you know it's good for me to
exercise some willpower i want to
develop this or i can remind myself of
the health effects or i can think about
the fact that you know after not smoking
for three or four days i suddenly taste
a lot more you know and i could be like
well i kind of want to hold on to this i
don't i don't want to get rid of that
just by indulging myself in that
particular
bad habit right so so there are
ways in which we can
bring cognitive remedies you could say
any other questions about this one i
think we're more or less on time as far
as
things go
otherwise i'll just jump right into the
next one
which is a little bit more
concrete you could say at least in its
imagery
should we go right into that one
the one about the dinner party
or banquet
as it's translated
well andy says sounds good because this
is her favorite one so
um
so
i actually want to point something out
about about terms here so when it says
banquet the greek word for that is
actually symposia
and so this this is a coming together to
drink and eat what we would nowadays we
could call it a banquet a dinner party
it's some sort of occasion right and
this is an extremely important part of
the ancient world and its culture
so he says in chapter 15 remember that
you ought to behave in life as you would
at a banquet as something is being
passed around it comes to you
you stretch out your hand and take a
portion of it politely it passes on do
not detain it or it has not come to you
yet
do not project your desire to meet it
but wait until it comes in front of you
so act towards a ch towards children
towards a wife so towards office so
towards wealth
so what are the basic ideas here well
you're at a party right
and there's there's things coming around
as he says don't don't throw don't
stretch out your don't project your
desire to meet it the greek word there
is epibala which literally means to to
throw at right don't throw your desire
out there at the i don't know the shrimp
cocktail or or the uh
what are other things that people glom
onto you know there's like a
particularly nice hors d'oeuvre and
everyone's like oh i'll take three of
those you know no no just take one take
take your fair share right and don't
throw your desire all over the place
looking for the things there's something
probably in front of you
have some of that even if it's like you
know
just potatoes
um potatoes can be quite nice right so
and epictetus is saying it's okay
to take the things that do come your way
it's it's not okay to like take the
whole dish
and just sit there and eat away at it
right because then you're depriving
other people of their fair share but
it's okay to take your portion uh you
know what we could call a fair and
fitting share and then it's really
important to allow things to pass on not
not to try to hold on to them right
imagine that you're at a
dinner and people are passing dishes
around and you just pile them up in
front of you just in case you want some
of them later on that's that's that's
bad behavior you're being a jerk right
you're monopolizing all of the wonderful
dishes they're probably also going to
get cold by the time they get to other
people
so
you know
focusing too much
on what's not in front of us but what
what you know we're hoping to to come
along
or you know trying to hold on to things
too too long
um
it's not just in terms of eating and
drinking it's also in terms of
everything else as he points out act
this way towards your children towards a
spouse towards office towards wealth now
there is a danger
actually this goes right to dirk's
question
ways beginners get mixed up about this
being too passive right you're not an
oyster this this uh mollusk that like
finds its place and just sits there and
never does anything
um and actually let me let me take this
question because i'm sure we'll have
others and this is really uh
good for this isn't that a very passive
attitude wouldn't a stoic also try to
make a difference to the better trying
to make it come along so a stoic
wouldn't try to make it come along
because there's already a procedure in
place we already have norms about how we
do things at dinner parties that
epictetus is invoking
it's perfectly fine to follow functional
norms that work the way that they should
and you're gonna get your fair share you
know um
i mean if you were if you were uh
sitting there and you're at the very end
of the table
and everything comes to you and
everything's already you know taken out
of the dishes by the time it gets you i
think it would be perfectly fine to like
go up to the host and say hey this isn't
working here right this is
non-functional
but at most dinner parties you know
you're going to get what you need i mean
it's interesting because andy and i will
go out and you know go to places with
fine dining
um or to events where they're doing
things and you know i'm a big guy you
know i i can eat a lot and
um
[Music]
you know i'm sometimes not getting as
much food as i'd like well i don't i
don't go and bogart stuff at the table i
i can address that in another way when i
get home i can have a snack you know
eat some
mixed nuts you know some good protein
some string cheese or something like
that right so it's it's not condemning
you to pure passivity to say that when
you're in this situation
you should behave this way
and you know we can i think this will be
helpful when we get to the contemporary
examples
but let's look at some of the examples
that epictetus himself provides
and some of these are very food focused
so he says
just as the propositions it is day and
it is night this is in chapter 36 are
full of meaning when separated but
meaningless if united so also granted
that for you to take the larger share at
dinner is good for your body
it's bad
for what the maintenance of the proper
kind of social
feeling there's an overriding value here
it's good for your body
to take more food take more than your
fresh air it's bad for you as a person
and for the community that compromises
the banquet or dinner party
so he says
when you're eating with another person
remember to regard not merely the value
for your body of what lies before you
but also
to maintain your respect for your host
for the for the one who's you know gone
to the expense of putting on the party
on in chapter 46 he says on no occasion
call yourself a philosopher do not for
the most part talk among laymen about
your philosophical principles but do
what follows from your principles so for
example i love this one at a banquet
do not tell people how they ought to eat
but eat as a person should
likewise make no display to the lay
people of your philosophical principles
but let them see the results which come
from these principles when digested and
so you know how should a person behave
at a banquet well like like he said
don't take more than your fair share
don't start letting your desire go out
to all sorts of other things
it's going to interfere with your dining
experience of actually eating the food
that that you've got and so you know
let's think about some contemporary
examples i actually have one um
that came up i think it was in twitter
um somebody messaged me and was looking
for advice about their studies
and they said that they were you know
interested in studying philosophy
and they knew that they had to
read books more than once and they were
using plato as an example and they're
saying that you know they've read some
platonic dialogues two or three times
and they're finding they're getting
bored with it they're not you know
they're not getting more out of
subsequent readings but
instead they're they're just seeming to
cover old ground right
and then what else was in their message
which i thought was really telling
is that um
they find themselves thinking about all
these other philosophers who they
haven't read that they're anticipating
reading like hegel
or nietzsche or
i think rene descartes might have been
in there or whoever
and as i read through their thing i was
like
i think these two things are probably
related you know because the experience
that you typically have rereading
a classic work of literature is that you
get more out of it the next time around
i'm sure all of you have had this
experience right you read plato's mino
the first time and you're like okay i
think i got what's going on here you
read it a second time you're like
holy crap i missed this thing over here
then you read it the third time and
you're like oh
i also missed this thing this thing and
this thing and then you're like the
fourth time you're like oh these things
are interconnected and then you know
you're like wait a second socrates who
says he doesn't actually know anything
he knows a whole bunch of things you
know you're getting more and more out of
it
that's not going to happen
if while you're trying to read the plato
you're already like projecting this
future out there where you've read all
these other people that you don't know
anything about it's like being at the
banquet and having a perfectly good dish
in front of you that you you can take
some of and put on your plate and eat or
however else they did you know scoop it
up with bread or you know however they
did things in ancient times
and instead of like tasting the food and
savoring it you're like looking at the
next dish down the line
you miss out on things that way right
so this can apply to our reading um i
think this applies a lot to a lot of
people when they're dating or married
and they're you know they have what we
call a wandering eye you know your your
spouse or boyfriend or girlfriend or
whoever
your partner should be good enough for
you if they're not well maybe you know
you need to think about that
relationship but if you're there in the
present with them
then you know
maybe you shouldn't be looking over
there uh for for somebody else um jobs
you know there's a lot of people who
don't do
uh very good jobs or have satisfaction
now there's a lot of crappy jobs out
there i'm not gonna i'm not gonna deny
that right there's a lot of inequities
and jobs but you could have a decent job
and then you're always thinking about
like you know the grass being greener on
the other side as we say
purchasing in consumption right you buy
yourself um
i don't know let's say you're into shoes
i'm not really into shoes
but there's lots of people who are so
you buy yourself a new pair of shoes and
you're like oh man these are going to be
so great and then you go you know
walk around in them and it turns out
they don't fit that well
at first you got to break them in and
you're already like thinking about the
next five pairs of shoes you're gonna
get right
i mean i'm just kind of making this up
out of the air but i think you can you
can relate to this right there's many
many ways
in which people get too focused on
the dishes that either are coming around
but aren't yet here which they are
hoping for
or they want to hold on to the dish that
they've got and not let it pass on
um instead of just actually focusing on
the dish that we we have in in front of
us which
is probably going to be
sufficient now again to go back to the
passivity thing let's say the dish isn't
that good does that mean like you
shouldn't reach your hand out and take
some salt and sprinkle it on it
no
that's perfectly fine right
you know you don't need to go to the
salt mine and and mine some you don't
need special himalayan sea salt
or something like that in order to make
it a good dish um so
any any questions about this one it's
this wonderful
very um
very concrete metaphor but it sure
applies to a lot of things
in our existence if you can do this you
will certainly be a lot freer
and happier
any any questions or any uh other
examples that people want to bring up
you know of uh
not paying
what is the phrase that we have in we
say
focus on your own page right if you're
taking taking a test or doing homework
you work on your own page not on
somebody else's
eyes on your own page that's what people
say right
andy says keep your eyes on your own
paper yeah so
any other examples that people can think
of though i think there's like
literally thousands of of things that we
might
um be extending our desire throwing our
desire out into
dishes that are not
our own
you know it can even ruin like gameplay
um
you know i i saw my kids playing
minecraft eyes on your fries that's a
good one too i saw my kids playing
minecraft and they'd be like oh it's
going to be so awesome when i'm able to
do this thing within the game and you're
like how many hours is that going to
take you
oh you know it's going to be a long long
time first i've got to do this then do
this then do this then do this and
you're like are you having fun right now
i'll have fun when when i get there and
you're like that's not oh minecraft
grieving okay so if people don't know
what grieving is
that's if you play in a shared world and
you make something and then somebody
else comes along and like sets a trap in
it or knocks it down or starts it on
fire or does things like that just to
just to mess with you
and actually that's a good example going
back to um the hindrance thing right if
if your goal if if you get really
wrapped up in a virtual world and your
goal is to accumulate whatever it
happens to be in that world
and the world is set up in such a way
that other people can mess with you you
are probably going to be
hindered at one point or another right
and it's tough when you've invested a
lot of time
and energy and thought into something to
not
be able to walk away from it and say
well that's
how things happen right you get upset
about that
okay so a says let's say the rest of the
guests are a bunch of wolves essentially
rat race business culture would it be
more appropriate to change tactics and
throw your desire at the food
if that's the case then you're not at a
dinner party you're not at a banquet
you're at like you said a
rat race business culture
feed or something like that and then
probably um it depends i mean
you could say this sort of thing isn't
for me um
i'm i'm not going to participate in this
i mean there's nothing that says that
you have to be in one place and not in
another
um
[Music]
you know throwing your desire at the
food if you could you could do this
without throwing your desire at the food
you could say
okay what's the rational thing to do i
do need to get something to eat
um
i don't necessarily need to be like
emotionally invested in that i just need
to make sure that i get my fair share
maybe i'll
sneak around over here and get a head in
the order or something like that and you
you could do that without um getting
yourself all you know worked up and and
having your desires going further than
they they need to
nancy says uh
you've given me a lot to think about i'm
actually doing the complete opposite
learning about stoicism oh i've bought
dozens of books i haven't had the time
to read i know i have to manage this
better
i think that's kind of common actually
when you find something
that
you're benefiting from
and you think is interesting
to
i mean it could be books at least you're
not saying oh and by the way i also
bought myself 20 challenge coins
i got myself a stoic tattoo or something
like that things that are like totally
extraneous to to stoicism buying books
at least
okay the books have some knowledge in
them that you can use you don't have to
read them all at once as a matter of
fact
think about this
you
make yourself a dinner party of books
you're the only guest
nobody's going to take your books away
from you
just read this one book and
you know enjoy it or savor it or get
what you want out of it
and i guess it's less like like a dish
and it's more like a meal you've got
this whole meal for yourself here
and then you know
you can move on to the next meal
maybe you don't buy any more books until
you've gone through the books you you
have but books are great i mean this is
a total digression but one of the cool
things about books is you can
read them
and then if you want you can pass them
on to somebody else right and it's not
like the knowledge goes away that you
had
um
it's really quite wonderful i actually
have a
a friend and old client
who buys a lot of books and then he
he reads them and then he sends them to
me and he says hey either you can use
the book or you can
sell it to somebody
or you can find somebody else who can
use the book let's keep these things in
circulation right so i mean a book is a
dish that unlike other dishes or a meal
it's not lost in the consumption of it
right
so that's kind of a cool idea
um
let's go on to the next one
before we we run out of time um
this is the last one eliminating envy i
call it and this is this is a big
problem for for lots and lots of people
in chapter 9 he says beware lest when
you see some person
preferred to you in honor of possessing
great power or otherwise enjoying high
repute
you are never carried away by the
external impression and deemed them
happy
for if the true nature of the good is
one of those things that's under our
control
there's no place for either envy or
jealousy and you yourself will not wish
to be a prator or senator or a consul
but a free person
there's only one way that leads to this
this is to despise the things that are
not under our control
now notice that he's talking about
something that we began this session
with external impressions right
when you have this impression that
somebody is being preferred to you
somebody's being elevated above you
somebody's being given the attention
that you're not getting
don't be led away by that don't don't
engage in mistaken automatic or implicit
or however we want to say subconscious
reasoning processes because there's more
to the story
than just that we need to think about
what's actually
being said here
so
what is being said he's saying you know
um
don't assume that these things make
people happy because a lot of times they
don't
right
if
the true nature of the good is
something that's under our control
then even if you don't have what those
other people have you can be perfectly
happy
we have the good we get to be free we
have
what we
need it's sort of like the old song
right uh you can't always get what you
want you know the the rolling stone song
but sometimes you get what you need
the stoics are saying you can get what
you actually need uh all the time a lot
of the things that you want are not
really things that you need in order to
be to be happy
now
one of the things that he says here that
i want to go into a little bit so he
uses these two terms in the english
envy
and jealousy
what's the difference between these two
the greeks actually had two different
words that the stoics gave definitions
of
envy is
thonos
um
it's that you know fee
t and then then the th the fee the theta
makes that weird sound
right phonos
and it's uh that's that's a pain at
seeing somebody else getting something
something that you don't have something
that you would like to have so you can
be envious of somebody else
um quite easily right you can envy them
for honor you can envy them for
great power you can envy them for
people liking them you could envy them
for all sorts of other things you know
they're kids going to a better school
they're the clothes that they have the
connections uh the fact that they went
to
this this you know school or work in
this place
um their you know physical appearance
versus yours there's a million things we
can be envious about right
so
that's not a good emotion to have all of
you know what envy feels like right
we talk about it as gnawing at you it
sucks it doesn't feel good at all
the other thing is what they called
zelotupia
in greek
and there's actually uh i'm going to
give you a couple definitions not coming
from epictetus but from other people
writing about this cicero in the
tuscalon disputations when he's
presenting the stoic theory of the
emotions
he calls it distress arising from the
fact that the thing one has coveted
oneself is in the possession
of the other person
arius didymus
calls it pain at another also getting
what you yourself had a
desire for
and you know we we often talk about
being jealous of people
in terms of relationships right so
um
my wife spends too much time talking
with this person over there at the party
and if i'm the jealous type right i'm
over there and i'm what are you talking
about you know i'm worried about what
losing
something or sharing something even you
know the exclusivity of affection with
this this other person
and you know we can be jealous of all
sorts of things and envious about all
sorts of things
so
[Music]
if we don't want to feel that sort of
thing we can remind ourselves that we've
got enough we're okay we have what we
what we need
and we can also say
if things are good for another person
then
maybe we shouldn't begrudge them getting
that good you know if we really if we
believe that having the corner office
you know so to speak is this wonderful
wonderful thing which it's not you know
i mean you can be just as miserable in a
corner office as you can be down in the
proverbial mail room or you know washing
dishes or anything like that but let's
say we think it is good
why do we begrudge people that why not
just say
good for them you know
more power to them as we say
and epictetus has a couple good good
passages where he talks about this
chapter 25 he says something very
similar has someone been honored above
you at a dinner party or in salutation
or being called in to give advice
if these matters are good you should be
happy that he got them you can like be
proud or happy or whatever for that
person if evil don't be distressed
because you didn't get it you avoided
you know as we say you dodged a bullet
you avoided an evil
and
bear in mind that if you don't act the
same way that others do with a view to
getting things that are not under our
control you can't be considered worthy
to receive an equal share with others
last session we talked about that
passage at greater length and we said
you know you have to consider the prices
of things that you're willing to pay and
so you know if you think that it really
is great to as we said um enjoying high
repute
then
you know if you think that that's really
going to
uh make you happy you're kind of in a
bad way from a stoic perspective but if
you think that's really going to make
you happy then you have to pay that
price and to want the thing without
paying the price
it's kind of silly right
he's he's also got a really great um
line here in chapter 24.
he says and i think many of us can
relate to this in in many ways
let not these reflections oppress you
i will live without honor and be nobody
anywhere
if lack of honor is an evil
you cannot be an evil through the
instrumentality of some other person any
more than you can be in shame it's not
your business is it to get office or to
be invited to a dinner party certainly
not how then can this be a lack of honor
and how is it that you will be nobody
anywhere
when you ought to be somebody only in
those things under your under your
control
so i mean many of us i think have
struggled myself included
with this
bad feeling of being nobody being being
somebody who
doesn't count who doesn't have as we say
like a seat at the table or a stake in
things right
and that if we think about ourselves
that way it's kind of hurtful
epictetus is telling us
that we don't have to you know
view ourselves as nobody we're somebody
we're just not somebody in terms of
honor or in terms of you know office and
power or in terms perhaps of you know
physical attractiveness or or pick
whatever else you want i'll never be a
young person again right i'm 51 years
old and this is it that's i'm just going
to get older from this point onward
we don't have to be jealous of people or
envious of people
over these matters thinking that if we
just got them we would be somebody it's
up to us whether we want to be somebody
the last one that i want to bring up
he says this is in chapter 44. the
following statements constitute a
non-sequitur i'm richer than you are
therefore i am superior to you
or i'm more eloquent than you are
therefore i am superior to you
but the following conclusions are better
i'm richer than you are therefore my
property is superior to yours or i am
more eloquent than you are therefore my
elocution is superior to yours but you
are neither property
nor elocution and this kind of goes back
to
some of the the points that we were
making
earlier uh in the start of the session
about um impediments right the
impediments have to do with things that
are external to us that we can have and
use but are not us i'm not my wealth or
my elocution or the clothes that i wear
or anything like that i am the
internal things my
my faculty of choice my mind my habits
all of those sorts of matters so
we again if we think about these sorts
of things that will help us not be as
jealous or envious of other people who
seem to be doing quite well right and
sometimes infuriatingly well right we're
like they don't deserve any of that
right um we can be jealous and envious
of people who do deserve it and
i wish i had that too but it's awfully
really galling when we see
um somebody who we think doesn't deserve
it getting getting
really bi in the world isn't it
um and i think you know to think about
contemporary examples and we'll take
questions um
it's it's a little bit tougher i would
say in our hyper-connected internet
media rich
you know advertising being targeted at
us all the time
age um it's very easy to make all sorts
of assumptions about how other people
are doing
and the wonderful life that they're
having
um which could be completely false these
are just appearances right the life that
people are living on facebook or
instagram or even twitter which is
probably a little bit you know more
pugnacious
in in nature
those are just tiny little windows very
often carefully managed into a person's
life they're not necessarily what that
person is is really living through and
so we want to think about
what will actually make us genuinely
happy it's probably not all those things
that we see other people having that we
then can be envious about you know
the things that will make us happy are
the things that we actually do have
control over dustin says i was recently
envious of a peer's career clarity
uh i didn't want anything on that path
but he was so clear i craved that that's
very interesting
funny thing to work through in the
passage made me laugh yeah i mean so
it's not being envious of the fact that
like their career is going well
it's envious of the fact that they
understand what's what's going on with
their career they have like you know
clear goals or something like that now
that's a really interesting one because
i think that
some of that is stuff in our control
right i think it it it does make sense
not necessarily to be envious or jealous
but to emulate people who we think
have clarity
if if they're clear about the right
things right
um i mean you could have a clear career
path
but as we say for evil right
you're like i i totally want to commit
genocide and i see all the right steps
to do it now there's a very far-fetched
you know example um that's that's not
something to be envious of right
or or emulate but if somebody is like i
want to be an architect
what do i need to do it well i got to go
to this school and i got to do this
thing and i've got to like do this
internship
that might actually be something kind of
admirable you know uh dustin says he's
in sales okay so it's probably something
like i want to i want to move this much
product or get this many customers or
follow up on this many leads it's
probably something some metric like that
then right so yeah that might be a
little bit different
um
all right so uh
gary says probably a more suitable
example
of than the song of the rolling stones
is the song of joe jackson
you can't get what you want until you
know what you want well that's that's a
very good one too yeah if a lot of times
and this goes back to the desires and
aversions things right
we have desires and aversions that if we
properly looked at them
and thought things through
the force of that desire or aversion
might might be lessened
you know because a lot of times what we
think we want
and what we actually do want not the
same thing right
we experience this all the time when we
actually do get what we think we want
and then we're not happy with it you
know we go to a restaurant we're like oh
i can't wait for this amazing meal you
know we get it get it in front of us and
then you know we start eating it oh the
first bite's so amazing right and then
after a while we're like uh
i don't i don't know why i ordered this
i don't really like it that much
so that's a good example
uh vincent a few years ago i could have
easily been envious of somebody
like johnny depp a wealthy celebrity
with a beautiful young wife then i got a
glimpse into his life behind closed
doors so another good point yeah a lot
of times um
so you know it could be that we actually
do get the experience that we want and
it doesn't measure up or we get to see
as you say behind closed doors we get to
see what the reality of that person's
life is and that they're not as happy
as they were
pretending to be as they they projected
themselves
as being as other people were saying
about them
and you know i think again to go back to
that point that i was making it's not as
if celebrities have not been around
before and people didn't dream oh if
only i
had wealth or you know social status or
power
um or you know a body in good shape or
beauty or something like that everything
would fall into place for me right that
that goes back
before even um
uh print media culture
um we see this in fairy tales and stuff
like that but it's become especially
difficult in our time
where we're so
bombarded and saturated with images you
know
constantly
not just informing us
but shaping pictures and
advertising you know is very much about
like
creating desire
where there wasn't desire or channeling
desire
um and so i think we have more
challenges in that respect than perhaps
previous generations did a says not on
the topic of any well that's that's fine
because we can we can take some general
questions we're actually close to the
end of the
the time but let's do some general
questions i wonder how to deal with
situations when i know that showing my
frustration or anger can change the
situation to my liking when rationality
calm discussion don't work and so using
the emotion is functional in that way
even though i let an external thing
desire get the better of me
it's a great question
seneca actually talks about
cases like that in his book on anger
which i would highly recommend um it's
it's a
it's a great um
like well what about this here's my
answer here's the stoic answer what
about this here's the stomach cancer
and yeah anger can be functional and
that's part of how i got in so much
trouble with anger because as a kid i
found that you know getting getting
angry and you know raising my voice and
you know sometimes even like um physical
uh you know
threats and violence and stuff like that
uh in some cases would get get what i
wanted right or at least protect me from
from other people and i think there's
lots of us in that boat
anger is even for those like aristotle
who think that you can you can feel
anger virtuously
and that sometimes you should get anger
very very dangerous because every time
that we're using it
it is creating a habit within ourselves
epictetus actually talks about this
in his
discourses there's actually several
chapters devoted to anger about these
sorts of things
so
i i actually myself i don't completely
follow the stoics and saying that anger
is always bad i'm a bit more
aristotelian but i think we have to be
like super super careful with it and we
have to be very cognizant of the kinds
of habits that we're forming or
reinforcing uh andrew here's a good
question to go out on
more recent philosophers that can
illuminate stoic principles montana for
example now montana is not all that
recent he's he's early modern
and who he's referencing there miguel de
montan
great great thinker
i love reading him in part because he
puts me in conversation with other
thinkers i love like like plutarch and
cicero
um there are in yeah there are many
people who have adapted
stoic principles and practices
and
you can find uh quite a few of them in
the early modern period montan is is uh
one of them
um there was an entire neo-stoic
movement that montana is usually like
placed within
and that lasts really into the
late 18th century the stoics are red and
you know sometimes misinterpreted by
people like say hume but but they at
least are reading them and citing them
and bringing them up rene descartes is
incorporating some stoic principles into
his his own ethics and stuff like that
um but there are people who focus
on the stoics and in the 20th and 21st
century
we have an embarrassment of riches
there's a vast variety of of quite good
books out there
um
schopenhauer is not not really stoic
and doesn't have much in common with
them as a matter of fact there's also
like plenty of people who who
like i mentioned hume misinterpret the
stokes and there's plenty of them in the
20th century as well
but let's focus on the people who don't
so
one of the books that was really really
instrumental in what we call the stoic
revival was lawrence becker's a new
stoicism where
he says imagine if the stoics never
disappeared as a movement and that they
were around and could engage
contemporary philosophy what would
stoicism look like and he reconstrues it
on that basis
we have you know all sorts of uh
thinkers some of whom are my colleagues
in stoicism today like uh
you know um christopher gill and
um john sellers two extremely prolific
scholars who have done so much to
to um bring stoicism you know into the
the present uh massimo
donald robertson tim labon
um you know we might think about some of
the people who we've had as as guests at
stoicon like margaret graver whose book
on stoicism and emotion is is a really
awesome work julia anas
who is not not a stoic herself but does
a lot of work on stoicism nancy sherman
you know we could go on and on and on
there are many really great
well-informed conscientious people
writing on stoicism
and you know looking at contemporary
examples
in the present day going going back into
you know all the way back into about the
1980s stoicism was probably less well
attended oh i should mention anthony
long
you know also a speaker at stoicon um so
there's lots of really great
scholars and works some of whom write in
very approachable ways not not in sort
of academic jargonies you know
um
dirk has a question about
procrastination i have a bad habit of
procrastinating any stoic ways of
dealing with it i mean there isn't any
like you know here's the stoic approach
to procrastination
directly from
uh
a text although epictetus does have does
have that chapter
near the end of the end caribbean
where
which could be helpful where he says
the olympic contest is before you you
know
how long are you gonna like not do what
you should do
you know so that that could be helpful
but i think the stoic approach would be
to say um what's going on when i
procrastinate why why am i
procrastinating why do i wrongly
view that as the appropriate rational
response
and
not see things in another way so that
that could be
that could be quite helpful as well
all right well we're a little bit over
time and i do have unfortunately to get
to some some other work for the day i'm
not yet at the point where i can take
sunday's completely off but thanks for
everybody for um
showing up and uh good questions and
comments hopefully this has been
illuminating and you can go back over
the
video at your leisure i think for three
weeks is how long it stays up on light
hall on this particular page um
everybody saying thanks you're very
welcome and thank you and um
check out the other stuff that we've got
coming up on light hall when it gets
posted it's not all there right now but
i'm going to be using
this platform for quite a while myself
and uh yeah i'll see you all somewhere
else in the
internets
you